rien
des au revoir que l'on craint être des
adieux
pour beaucoup de ces réfugiés syriens le
moment tant attendu de prendre la route
du canada était aussi le moment de
mesurer tout ce qui laissait derrière
tout ce qu'ils ont perdu à jamais genova
va rejoindre son frère à montréal avec
la guerre elle croit qu'il n'y a plus
d'espoir
cyril n'ont plus d'espoir peut-être mais
l'attachement profond à leur pays
demeurent des labeurs
c'est mon pays c'est là où je suis né où
j'ai grandi et élever ma famille dit une
fatima bouleversé je quitte ma famille
mes amis et lui aussi rejoint un frère
avec son mari et leurs six enfants
au delà des larmes ce grand saut vers
l'inconnu représente aussi pour ses 163
réfugiés une seconde chance
pas facile de choisir ce qui les
accompagnera dans cette nouvelle vie il
m'en demandait que qu'il faut seulement
j'avais un kilo pour les champs
personnes et c'est un nous sommes des
émissions et shows mais on est en même
temps on est très content parce qu'on va
commencer une nouvelle vie
pour le personnel d'immigration réfugiés
citoyenneté canada dont beaucoup sont
venus de partout dans le monde
sélectionnez les réfugiés ce tout
premier d'une longue série de vols
nolisés vers le canada était un moment
de grande fierté
visa pour le canada en main les réfugiés
syriens ont franchi la frontière
libanaise pour une dernière fois le
passage au contrôle de l'immigration
libanaise et une étape hautement
symbolique
une fois le visa de sortie tamponné dans
leur passeport les réfugiés syriens ont
officiellement quitté le liban la porte
d'embarquement numéro 6 de l'aéroport
rafic hariri avait été décoré pour
l'occasion comme noah les procédures
d'embarquement était lourde
une dernière fouille de sécurité avant
de pouvoir monter à bord certains
profitaient du retard pour se préparer à
la vie dans leur pays d'adoption
tous les réfugiés qui sont montés à bord
aujourd'hui sont attendus à rennais part
de la famille au canada ou des
organismes privés à pois jérôme au pôle
contribuables canadiens n'auront donc
pas à défrayer les coûts pour les aider
à s'établir
n'empêche tous ici ont tenu à exprimer
une profonde gratitude vers le canada
parce qu'il leur offre la possibilité de
contempler un nouvel horizon alors qu'il
s'envolait vers des cieux plus cléments
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
beyrouth